[Musique]
bienvenue dans le monde des drôles de
petites bêtes
ici tout le monde a son rôle
il y a la reine marguerite et votre
peuple bien aimé vous prépare une fête
des plus grandioses loulou le push
mireille l'abeille belle la coccinelle
mesure belge c'est bien siméon le
papillon marie la foule qui ne bouge pas
tu dois attendre lyon léo le bourdon et
bien sûr carole l'alucia mais cette
belle harmonie va bientôt être troublé
par l'arrivée d'un curieux visiteurs
apollon le drian amadou bah je vois la
vie un spectacle va pouvoir commencer
[Musique]
deby
écoute moi je te propose à marcher je ne
sais pas quoi dire je ne suis qu'un
étranger je vais sans tarder être
couronnée reine et gouverner à ta place
handball sera le plus grandiose qui déjà
existé contre rennes a disparu on est
tous à sa recherche
on aimerait d'un solide et les footeux
grillon de la rue
la couronne est arrêté il faut arrêter
le gagne
drôles de petites bêtes
[Musique]
oh
le 13 décembre au cinéma